Let's talk about remote work. Part two of
three.
Welcome back to another episode of
"Udacity Career Tips" my name is Martin
McGovern, and today we are going to be
addressing part two of an audience
question about remote work. This question
comes from LinkedIn and asks, "What are
the efforts that one has to put in in
order to achieve a remote job?". This is a
big question and one we won't be able to
fully cover in a video like this but I
did put the question to the LinkedIn
community and got some responses from
folks to hear how they found their first
remote job. The majority of people who
responded said that they got their first
remote job by turning their in-person
job into a remote position. Now, the way
they did this was that they showed a
history of accomplishing their tasks, and
self-management. They had a good rapport
with their boss. And they started small.
They started doing a couple days a week
from home, before eventually
transitioning completely into a remote
position. Now, if you're looking for your
first job, you're looking to change
industries, or you're just looking for
your first remote gig and you don't have
one right now; it's gonna be a bit hard
to turn your current job that you don't
have into a remote job. So, what can you
do to help improve your chances? The real
difficulty in finding a remote job is
building trust with the person that you
don't get to sit down with one-on-one. In
an in-person interview or an office
environment you get to interact with a
lot of people in the room, so it's easy
to get a sense of who you are, how you
act, and how well you fit in. But, if your
remote, you don't get to have that
face-to-face contact. So, as you're
thinking about applying for remote jobs,
your online personal brand is going to
be extremely important.
Are there any videos that I can watch?
Any audio I can listen to? Any projects
that I can interact with to see who you
are, how you work, and the type of a tone
that you bring to a team? So, if you're
really interested in getting a remote
job, and you don't have a job that you
can turn into a remote job at this time,
be focused on building a personal brand
that showcases who you are, so you remove
doubt and increase trust in the
conversations that you're having.
If you have anything to add to this
point please put it in the comments. This
is part two of a three-part question so
join us again next week as we answer
part 3. Which is the pros and cons of a
remote job - and a little bit of a teaser,
I work remote! So, I have a bit of a
insight into that one. We also are really
excited to be collecting questions from
you to answer in future videos so please
put those in the comments as well. We
appreciate you for watching and wish you
the best of luck in your job search!